Okay, so now we move into your budget presentation.
You thank you.
I'll be quick. So this is the budget presentations for Finance
Department.
You should have a handout in front of you.
Before I begin the first slide, please let
me quickly introduce the key players in the Finance Department. I know you've
met William Jones. You may already interacted
with some of these excellent team players in this Finance
Department supporting me in leading this department.
I just want to make sure we have the slides.
Okay, well, while we're waiting on
that, I know you have your handout. That will be slide two.
In your handout, we have six divisions in
the Finance departments. Again. From the director's office,
we have Bernita Jones. I don't know if she's here.
If not, so if I call your name, please do stand up
so that I don't have to look back. So we have Fernita
Jones, who of course you all met and very familiar who support
the Council's Office. We have Rochelle McHenry.
Anushi is here. Thanks Rochelle. She supported
the Houston fire departments. We also have William Bryan,
who support the Houston Information Technology. Thank you,
William. We have Sheila Murphy, who also supported the
business office in the finance department. Thank you.
The next division is Treasury Capital Management. Of course, you all know Melissa Dubovsky,
who's not here today. We also have financial planning
analysis. William Jones, who you've met.
The next one is the financial reporting and operations by
Are sheet. Just want to make sure you know the face
and the name together. And, of course, we have the strategic procurement
divisions. Jerry Adams. There you go.
Our chief procurement officer. And last but not least is the
Performance improvement, Jesse Bounds. If he's here,
the computer froze in the back. So just keep working. Okay,
so again, Finance Departments has two funds.
So we have the general fund for Citywide Surfaces
as well as the revolving fund,
which is a surface chargeback for financial services provided to certain departments.
So with that, we are moving to the next slide. Slide number
three, if you can, flip your page again on the Functional
Organization charts chart. In the general fund, the finance budget is
at 20.8 million with 116
FTEs in this. So again, you saw the
functional indirector's office from the Council Administration's,
legislative Analysis, TPIA Coordinations,
the Treasury Capital Management at 2.9 million.
This is the area that handles the capital budget,
planning, management, reporting and Analysis, the debt issuance
and Derivative monitoring,
economic Modeling and Projection, the City's financial alternative,
liquidity alternatives, tax and Revenues Management.
I know Melissa often would come before councils to give a presentation
on upcoming financial transactions. That division also
handles the OPEP and pension system analysis,
financial planning analysis. Budget at 2.5
million. Again, this is FTEs at 16. But as you
saw, we have very limited active
employees at this point. Again, that division handling
the citywide annual operating budget, the five year forecast,
providing revenues and expenditures projections. We have the monthly
financial reporting, mid year review, funds management and any ad
hoc financial reporting the next on the financial reporting operations.
So again, this is a broad mix of Citywat Accounting
and reporting operations from the Accounting Disaster
Recovery to Fixed assets Management, grants Management including
the trust Funds management and Accounts Receivable is
at $6 million. Budget at 29.2
FTEs. Strategic Procurement of course, as the name
implies, handling the Citywide procurement,
administrations Material Vendor Contract Management, peacock Administrations
budget at 5.9 million at 44.7
FTEs. And again we have the Performance Improvement
divisions in here at 440,000. This is the
Office of Innovations that deals with the citywide operational process
improvement from citywide data analytics to smart
city program management. Continuing on to the next
slide, which is the revolving fund. This is budgeted at
7.5 million at 60.2 FTEs.
Again this slide. It provides financial services
to fleet hits fire departments,
grants management for Housing department.
This fund also handles the Citywide Energy Financial
Management as well as accounts payable function for certain departments.
Director's Office budget at 1.4 million.
This is the Fiscal Administrators to oversee the financial management
for Hits and Fire departments. That includes the annual budget,
monthly financial report and any ad hoc financial analysis.
And in the treasury and Capital Management budget
at 267,000. This is only two FTEs in here
supporting client departments for Capital Planning and cost
benefit analysis. This is for Fleet
Hits and Fire as our
client departments for the Capital Management financial
planning analysis at 885.5 thousand.
This is at 5.3 FTEs. This is handling the
Energy Financial Management supporting the fleet Departments sorry,
Energy Financial Management for GSD and also supporting the Fleet
Managements in their operating annual budget and monthly financial
report. Strategic procurement at 1.3
million. We have 9.9 FTEs in here.
This is again supporting the procurement for Fleets,
Hits and Fire departments.
One thing I want to note on the financial reporting operations,
I don't know if I think I probably missed it. Financial reporting
operations at 3.6 million. This is handling the Invoice reconciliations
and payments for several departments including Hits,
Public Works, Fire Departments and Planning as well as the
payment on the Energy Management, that is the electricity and natural gas
bills that we have to pay as well as
the service chargeback processing including the EMS Billing.
That is all in this revolving fund.
Moving on to the next slide. Slide five
again. I'm just going to go briefly again. You all know what we do
in the Finance Department. This is the major services in the Finance departments
is managing the Citywide Debt and Capital Management budgeting
forecasting, citywide Energy Contracts,
financial Reporting and Auditing, grants Management Oversight,
Disaster Recovery as you're all aware, as well as
the Cdwat procurement.
Next slide on the statutory requirements
for service delivery. I want to
stress out, we do have to comply with the statute
requirements for what we do in the Finance Department, that is from ensuring compliance
with the Texas Tax Code and Propositions One
and H to make sure that the city present a balanced budget in
accordance with state law and financial policies. We also
have to follow the federal and state compliance, including the procurement
law that we have to out comply and also completion
of the annual financial and single audit, again to be in
compliance with the state and federal laws. So again,
any mismanagement of these functions will be impacting the cities tremendously
from uninformed decisions from you all and the mayor's procurement
failure that will impact the surface delivery and city operations,
to claw back the federal funds and even to defaulting of the city
debt. So it is important for us in our function in the
finance departments to comply with all of these laws for
the sustainability of the city's operations.
So let's start looking into the numbers at this point.
I know we don't have the slides. So again, slide seven.
So on the General fund, again, we have 2.1
billion. The bulk of the property tax and sales tax is in the
Finance Department's business area,
$2.1 billion general fund in fiscal year 23,
which is 51.5 million higher compared to
the fiscal year 22 estimates. That is about 2.5% increase.
I know we've went a great deal in the budget overview on the
property tax and sales tax as we
saw it initially. Again, to keep in mind,
property tax and sales tax alone is comprised about
98.7% of the financial revenues in
the revolving fund. We have about 7.5 million in here, but again,
this is a surface chargeback so it is essential revenues as we recover
the cost of providing financial services to this department.
So the next slide, slide eight is going through the details
again. Again, as we mentioned, our property
tax is at $1.28 billion, reflect an increase of 48.9
million compared to fiscal year 22 estimates. Again,
this is based on the Propositions One and H and again,
this is based on the CPI inflation rate of
4.28% and 0% growth of
populations on the sales tax. Again,
we've covered this before, our sales tax revenues
is at $807,000,000, which is assuming no growth at
this point. Again, we continue to monitor. We've seen some upticks in fiscal
year 2022, but again, with so many uncertainties and
even going through the consultant review,
we felt that it's probably best to just keep it flat at this point because
of those uncertainties in the inflations for fiscal year 23
budget for mixed beverage taxes at 20.7 million reflects
about $570,000 increase from fiscal year 22 estimates.
Next slide, which is slide nine, this is the expenditure
site on the again,
a combined budget that we have in fiscal year 23 is
about 28.3 million. 20.8 million
is for General Fund and 7.5 of that is for
thank you revolving Fund.
So we'll go through the details in the next slide.
Slide ten thank you. So,
slide ten, this is just again the compositions on the
general fund for the personnel versus non personnel.
Again, personnel compress about 76% in
the general fund of 15.8 million and 24%
or 5 million is the non personnel of which if you look at the
pie charts on the right that comprise of
billing collections about 1.3 million. So that is the billing collections
where we pay for the Harris County tax office for the property
tax collected. We also have an audit, auditing contracts
1.6 million. This is with the auditing
contracts for the year end audit that we work closely with the
controller's office restricted account at 949,000
compressed about 19% and services which is 1.1
million. So this is where we have the printing costs, advertising costs,
parking rentals and so some of those consultants
happy with the outcome based budgeting for instance, is all in that services
category. So now we
look@the.net change from the fiscal year 22 current budget
on the next slide. So let's start with the operating budget
in fiscal year 22 started at 17.9 million.
Again with the adjustment as you saw in the general appropriation,
we have restricted account, hope and health benefits adjustment
including the city council surplus for a one time adjustment that I graciously
thank you for Fernita Jones office. So our fiscal
year 22 current budget at this point with those adjustments at 19
million. So now moving on to the incremental increases
to come up with our fiscal year 23. So again,
that city council surplus is a one time adjustment. So we took it out this
budget, it does include funding for ten new positions. So I
did ask for funding for ten new positions in my departments.
This is to help assisting the Strategic Procurement
Grants offer site and also capital Management.
Again, with this federal money that we have, we need more
streamlined process and help in those procurement divisions
as well as the Grants offer site. And so with
that our changing from operating budget
from fiscal year 22 reflect about 5.8%.
Now I'm going to move on to restricted account and health benefits and hope pay
increases. So those contractual mandate increases
about 621,000. So in total our
budget increased by 1.6 million. So that comprised
about 8.6% from the fiscal year 22 current budget.
So those are the details that increase decrease from fiscal
year 22 to fiscal year 23 expenditures budget.
Next slide. Again, I mentioned this briefly
when we go through the net change again, our budget includes
for both General fund and revolving fund, includes funding for health benefits,
pension contributions and the 3% hope pay increases.
Again in general fund it does include funding for ten new employees,
new positions to keep up with the increasing workload.
This is dealing with the Strategic procurement and the grants management as well as the
capital and debt functions revolving fund.
Again, this is just to provide funding for
financial procurement and accounts payable receivable support to
hit Fleet and Fire, as well
as the energy management. Again, it's very straightforward.
I think that's the end of my presentations and I'm open for any questions.
Thank you, council Member Abby Cayman. Thank you,
Director Emo. Again, I just wanted to thank you for all
the work you and your team do, and even in other
efforts that we as council are undertaking,
we come to you and you're always willing to help us and support us.
So thank you for making our jobs a lot easier.
I'm going to be asking this question of every department.
Given the significant budget constraints
that the city continues to face, are there priority
items that your department is not going to
be getting in this budget?
If not be getting yeah,
thank you for asking that question. So, one thing's first.
With the Pandemic and a lot of the grants funding we have,
the first party I ask for the mayor, is to make sure that we have
enough resources to carry those reporting and making sure
that federal monies are spent in compliance.
So I am gracious enough to get those decisions funded,
as you see in this budget, and that includes the procurement
groups. Again, we handle city wide functions
in here from the grants offer side and the procurement. So I
think I don't have anything else at
this point. Again, it may change because,
again, we've talked about great resignations and competitiveness
with the market. And I think, again, this is happening in all across the
board, that everybody's seeing that. And so I
may come then. But at this point, since this is the start of the fiscal
year, I have been graciously granted those
funding. Thank you, Council Member Ed Pollard.
Thank you, Mayor Pro Tim. And sorry if these questions
were asked earlier, but I just wanted to kind of get a general overview
for the public on just how financially sound stable
we are currently. I know we throw out a lot of numbers and
this is kind of a high level overview, but for the
general person that's just tuning in,
would you say that the city right now is financially sound?
Yes. So I just want to point out, so for
credit rating agencies to change
their outlook from negative to stable is a
great deal for the items
that the mayor had accomplished with the pension reform and
the OPEC reform. Those credit rating agencies really
recognize the leadership, including you all,
to managing the financials of the city of Houston. So, yes, we are
currently financially sound. Are there any specific shortfalls that
you see that we need to be aware of?
It depends on where we go, where the path we are moving
forward at this point. And I think that's why I stress enough about preserving this
fund balance, because we can be in the path that we should.
Has the administration identified specific
allocations regarding the ARPA dollars that will be
coming in that we need to be aware of. So I know I
mentioned to you about we have $160,000,000 of ARPA funding
in here. And I know Mayor mentioned
about the use of the ARPA dollars for
the revenue losses in the next year. I know
there's other projects that have been
presented and I think you all have seen it as well. The ones if Houston,
for example, is part of the ARPA fundings and I
can give you the list, I think we have the ARPA website already open,
so we can give you those details. Well, I want
to thank you again as well for your leadership and your entire team.
Thank you for all the hard work and the long nights. We all appreciate
it. So thank you very much. Thank you. It means a lot. Council Member David
Robinson. Thank you, Mayor Protem. And following on the line of my two colleagues
with their last questions, I just want to say thank you for everything you're
doing. I think this is a good wrap up to the last two days where
we've heard from you, from the mayor in particular. And I know a
moment ago when you were acknowledging your staff, who we all feel very strongly about,
great job, everyone. You mentioned Vernita Jones, who was not in the
chamber at the time, and Vernita is here. So I just wanted to call
particular attention to her because she does a great job across the street
taking care of us and
our budgets for all our people. And to the point about impact
of the great resignation, I know she's had a lot of work
to do for a number of our offices. So I just wanted to ask
you one follow up question to that. I don't know if she heard it.
When she was absent, did you mean that you were zeroing out her budget?
Is that right? I find that hard to believe.
No. Okay. All right, thanks. Council Member Sally
Alcorn. Thank you. And good for you for
getting the ten new positions. I know you need them.
In the big book, you mentioned as one of your performance measures getting
in compliance with our financial policies 100%. I just see
that we're out of compliance on just two of them. One has to do with
internal controls and one on our credit rating.
Can you explain a little bit further about how we're going to come in compliance
with that? I think on the structurally balanced budget stuff, it's in progress,
but those two were out of compliance. So can you talk about
that? Yeah. So keep in mind when we
have that and we keep our bar high, which is good.
When we did the financial policy, I think it was based on fiscal year
2014, if I'm not mistaken. And a lot happened
from fiscal year 2014 to now. So there was
a time when we did get downgraded and I can't remember which one. And I
think, like I said, we were having a negative outlook and so
now we're moving back up. So we are in the right path just by that
change from negative to stable.
Let's start the change of the credit rating does not come overnight.
So it takes some steps because they want to make sure how you run in
that year and then the next year then they will change it. And so now
the fact that we change from the negative to stable is good. So the
next hope is with all this preserve fund balance,
hopefully we would get those additional increase in the credit rating so that we
can go back to the compliance compared to fiscal year 14.
On the risk assessment,
there was part of our budget reductions, to be honest with you, with the internal
audit, again, during fiscal year 14 to now, a lot of things happen.
The economy landscape has changed. So there was budget reductions
on the internal audit, so there was out of compliance. So we
are going back to see what we can do to put it back
in the compliance state. Okay, great. And I have some questions on specific
line items within general government and you're the appropriate person to
send those to correct? I mean, you can do that. I can tell
you the dollars on what so some of the operating
questions are probably will have to defer, but okay, we'll do those in writing.
Thank you. Thank you. And there are no other council members in queue.
And I made these comments yesterday.
The City of Houston budget is made up by the administration,
you and your staff and the mayor and presented to us and we make amendments
to it. But our final vote is either yes or no. We either accept it
or we reject it. I think this budget is
in the best shape of any budget I dealt with in my nine years
here. And it's because of you and your team and the diligence that
we put forward a year ago when we saw sales
tax revenue and a lot of our revenue gone down and we
made some specific budgetary cuts and we
see the good of those. So thanks for your leadership,
always enjoy working with you and your deputy
directors, mr. Jones and Ms. Dabowski, and your entire team. You all
do a great job day in and day out in a tough environment
and thanks for everything you do. And I do believe this budget
process is hopefully going to be one of the smoothest ones we see because of
some of the pain that you saw coming and you
made adjustments, you and your team. So thanks for that. We do have three
virtual public speakers. The first is Saba Blanding
star Six. Again, Ms. Blanding.
Star six. There you go.
Yes. Okay. There I'm unmuted. Can you hear me okay?
Yes. Wonderful.
I have a question kind of two sides of
probably the same coin. You mentioned the high number of Vacancies
going into the budget cycle.
Why is retention an issue for your department beyond
the great resignation and how can we improve it?
And then kind of alongside that and maybe kindred
to what council member came in, asked earlier. I'm just really
curious, in a perfect world, how many employees
does your department need ideally? Like what would be the
perfect number and what type of kind of similar
to this, what type of pay increases would there
be ideally? So I have a more pragmatic question about Vacancies
and retention and improving it and then just kind of I
would like to know the ideal number of employees so we can
kind of know the difference between what's happening and what is needed.
Okay, so it's
an interesting question. Let's start with the Vacancies at this
point. So we
are in the general fund departments, and you've gone through
the budget presentations with our limited revenue sources.
And so we have to continuously looking for efficiencies
and process improvements in the finance and city
department. Citywide, what happened
with the Pandemic? I think it changed and I think you probably know this too,
it changed the landscape of the global mindset
of employees and employer too, right?
So some private sectors can
provide those flexibilities that we don't at the city of Houston,
right? Because the work is different. We have people who
have to be here meeting citizens.
And the pay the market study,
again, it's hard to compete
with the private sectors. Of course, when you do a market study, you compare with
the same government, municipal employees.
And so we continuously looking at that. And of course it's a
vicious cycle, if I can say. The more work you do, the more burned out
you are, and then the more you are looking for other position elsewhere.
And so that's what happened. Retentions at the same time, because you don't have
enough people and you are overworked pay
increases, an ideal number of people.
And I can go back on the previous years
when we don't have any all of these cuts and to see what those
numbers are, you're probably looking at back in 2010 or
I mean 2008, if anything. Right. And I have to look at this FTEs
number. But those are difficult
situations to handle at this point, especially when you deal with the competitiveness
with the market. Thank you, jason Oliver,
before, there has been conversation about
unmet needs I'm really kind of interested in
because some departments come up and they say we're not able to do X,
Y and Z because of the limitations or because of the cuts that we've
made. And I'm less clear on how that
is working with the finance department. So I'm
interested and I'm curious about these kind of unmet needs for
finance. And then you had talked about a market study
comparing to municipal employees. You said that
we had kind of leveled out legal. And I'm wondering if
we are competitive if we're looking at municipal
finance employees. And I wanted to circle back to the
outcomes based budgeting because I'm
interested in if it's possible, like will you modify
your you had talked about changing your budget calendar during the
last presentation, so I'm wondering if you'll be
modifying it to better incorporate public input.
For example, many cities hold public workshops both before
and after a proposed budget is released to really get the community knowledgeable
about what's in there and make sure that their priorities are included. So three
things. First is unmet needs. Second, competitive based
on municipal employees. And then third, about modifying
the budget calendar as we shift to outcomes based
budgeting. Can you say the first one again?
Unmet needs. Unmet needs. Okay,
thank you. So again, I mentioned in some of my slide on the
finance departments, what we do in the finance department is
a lot of that is actually compliance with the state
and federal regulations. Right? You're talking about the
procurement, talking about, again, the debt
management making sure that we are not mismanaging
those and you don't want to have any stations when we are at the default.
At this point, the budget, which is again is
governed in the state and local policies and
again the grants disaster recovery.
What we do is essentially essential to the city.
And so I cannot say that I would not be meeting
those functions because it's
a must in that sense. So,
yeah, I cannot say that I cannot meet any demands because
the function that we do are directly affecting
out of compliance of the city to the state and
local charter. So the impact
is maybe, I don't know, maybe a late payment if that is the case.
But of course it bites you back because then you have to pay
late fees. For example, going back to your
comment, it's not unmet needs, but I probably will have a delay if I don't
have enough people in the procurements. But you don't want to have a
wrong product being delivered or you don't want to have a wrong scope
being written. So again, those expertise
in my area is very crucial because what we do is going
to be affecting the entire city's operations. So I
cannot stress enough the city wide functions that our departments handles.
So the last comment you have is the outcome based budgeting we will
have. And I think Mr. Jones had mentioned to you we
do have the Plan Houston process, and I think
the input that we want from the public is the priorities. Exactly what
do you want to see the city spend the dollars?
The outcome based budgeting is just a vision on how
it's going to look like. But I think the key that you are trying to
get is the input of the public for those priorities.
And I believe that is already in place. But I can double check, but those
are the priorities that need some input from the public.
Thank you. Next speaker is Mr. Doug Smith.
Thank you. I just want to go back to a question I asked earlier that
didn't get answered. We received
$300 million of ARPA funds and we're going to get another
300 million. And the first 300 million was used
last year. And then this coming budget, if I understand correctly,
but you're addressing the budget gap does not take into consideration
the next 300 million that we're going to receive. So that's
one question. And then is there somewhere
how you calculated the property tax? Because when I
look at the projected increase, it's 3.9%
over 2022. And I thought the state
law and I don't know the state law, but I thought the state law mandated
a three and a half percent increase. So I would like to see how
that calculation was done. And finally,
in the raw data under other interfund
services, which I understand you explained well, there's revenues
of $7,400,000.
And where does that revenue appear? If it does appear
in page 625 where
you list all of your revenues,
those are my questions. Okay.
So I think correct me if I'm wrong if I get it right,
your questions. The ARPA dollar that we are
receiving or to be received is $607,000,000.
About $303,000,000 has been received last May.
Another 303,000,000 will be received sometimes this month.
This includes the allocations of ARPA
of 160,000,000 at this point. That came from the first tranche,
which is $303,000,000.
Great. Yes. Thank you. That's what I thought. And the
next 300 million, you did not take that into consideration
when you talked about addressing the budget gap.
You said that you didn't include that in what the proposed gap
might be. Is that a correct statement? So the next
tranche, again, we have the one safe Houston. We have other stuff that has already
been included in the ARPA. And I
know I included projected gap for fiscal year 24,
with the hope is to also use the ARPA money then. But again,
that will be from the second tranche. Correct me if I'm
wrong. ARPA funds can be used until December 31,
2023. 424. Got it.
So 24. Okay. For us,
yes. The second questions you have is on,
I believe is it on the property tax calculations?
Yes. Because you're showing a projected 3.9%
increase. And I thought that new state law
mandated a three and a half percent increase. And I just like to understand
how that plays against our own property
tax cap.
So I know our proposed budget is including the 4.28%
increase of the CPI,
but remember, we also have the 90 million on the Prop
H. And I can go back to you again to
reconcile the 3.97%
versus the 4.23 of the CPI number, but some
of that could be from the Prop
H. Okay, well,
okay. What about the state cap is three. And a half percent.
How does that play into this?
I will have to get back to you on
those details on the calculations. I think there's also some
other annexations maybe included in the fiscal year 22
budget. Again, annexation is only when it's
available and only for twelve months. You don't use annexations every single year.
So maybe some other stuff in the fiscal year 22 estimates.
Just a reminder of any additional questions. If you want to send to District
E at houstontx Gov, we will answer them and get back to
you. A reminder to the council members council members should
submit any department budget workshop questions in a Word document and
we'll upload that to SharePoint and departments have been
directed to provide responses within 48 hours of the conclusion
of their presentation. Department responses will also be
uploaded on SharePoint and give us two minutes
and we'll transition. And my apologies to Chief Pena,
Chief West and Ms. McHenry for the delay.
I'm sure your presentation will be worth it.
So thank you. We will transition and Vice Chair Ed
Pollard will be sitting here two minutes.